1) The Dissolving Tooth: There are numerous
urban legends involving Coca Cola. In fact,
there are so many that these legends all now
have their own category known as “Colklore”.
The most popular is that if you were to leave
a tooth in a cup of Coke overnight, by morning
the tooth would be completely dissolved. Like
most of the other legends involving the popular
drink this is totally untrue.
2) Walt Disney is Cryogenically Frozen: This
is another one of those popular stories that
most of us have probably heard. It says that
Disney supposedly had his dead body frozen
in hopes that future technology could bring
him back to life. Unfortunately for all the
gossip magazines though, records show that
Disney was cremated in 1966.
3) Sewer Gaters: This story tells the tale
of how several alligators were brought up
from Florida to be kept as pets in New York
City. After they got too big and violent they
escaped into the sewers where they now live
freely. Dating back to the 1930s and spread
by sensationalist newspapers the story is
completely untrue yet continues to be circulated
to this day.
4) Mr. Rogers was a Navy SEAL: According to
this legend Mr. Rogers, the popular children’s
show host was once a Navy SEAL sniper in Vietnam
responsible for numerous deaths. It goes on
to say that the reason he always wears a sweater,
to cover up all of his tattoos. As you may
have guessed, Mr. Rogers was never a Navy
SEAL and he had no tattoos. In fact, he was
never even in the military, was a pacifist,
and an ordained Presbyterian minister.
5) The Kidney Heist: Immortalized on TV and
the internet, this legend dates back to 1997
when an email was circulated warning people
of a crazy new crime wave catching on in big
cities. It usually involves a traveling business
man being bought drinks by a stranger only
to wake up in a tub covered in ice with a
phone next to him telling him to call 911.
Covered in blood, he later learns that his
kidney has been removed by criminals who intend
to sell it on the black market. Although the
story almost sounds feasible with all the
craziness you see on the nightly news, even
after the National Kidney Foundation asked
victims to contact them, no one has come forward
nor is there any documented instance of this
occurring.
6) The Jedi Religion Form: This far reaching
hoax claims that if enough people fill out
“Jedi” as their religion on their census
forms, the U.S. government will have to make
it an official religion. At one point thousands
of people tried to do just that but to no
avail. Just because a large number of people
check something on a census form is not grounds
for introducing it as “official” anything.
911-tourist-guy7) The 9/11 Tourist Guy: Shortly
after 9/11, a photo began to circulate showing
a tourist standing atop one of the World Trade
Centers with one of the airplanes in the background
of the shot about to strike the tower. The
accompanying story explained how the camera
was found in the wreckage but the tourist
remained missing. Aside from all of the very
inconsistent details in the picture, the story
already seemed completely improbable and several
people came forward claiming to be the prankster
responsible. It wasn’t until recently, however,
that the real culprit was discovered in Hungary.
He has since apologized to the families for
making light of their situation.
8) Poisonous Daddy Long Legs: There has been
a persistent rumor circulating for some time
that the daddy long legs spider is the most
poisonous in the world but cannot kill humans
because its fangs are too small. Where this
rumor started no one knows but one thing is
for sure, the daddy long legs is certainly
not the most poisonous spider in the world.
If you’re going to be careful around spiders
we would advise keeping your eyes open for
the brown recluse or the funnel web spider.
9) USA, Japan: Yes, there is a town in Japan
called Usa. No, the Japanese did not rename
it after World War II so that they could legitimately
stamp their exports with the phrase “Made
in USA”. The town itself was named after
the Usa Shrine, built in 725.
10) Kennedy and the Jelly Doughnut: The legend
goes that Kennedy made a trip to Germany back
in the 60′s in an attempt to connect with
the German people. While giving a speech in
the capital he told the crowd, “Ich bin
ein Berliner” or “I am a Berliner”.
Apparently though, a “Berliner” is also
a type of German pastry. Since then numerous
stories have circulated claiming that he was
practically laughed off stage afterwards.
The truth is, however, that that the crowd
understood him perfectly and nary a single
eyebrow was raised at the statement. You can
read more on why he said this statement completely
correctly here: John F. Kennedy’s Statement
“Ich Bin Ein Berliner” was Not Interpreted
as “I am a Jelly-Filled Doughnut”
11) The Good Samaritan: Circulating for years
this legend tells the story of a motorist
who stops on the side of the road to help
someone fix their flat tire. The person being
helped then asks the motorist for his address
to send a reward. Several weeks later the
motorist receives $10,000 in the mail. Over
the years this story has been attributed to
several celebrities, most recently Donald
Trump.